j'ai quelques autres cartes un peu plus
rares mais malheureusement elles sont
dans mon dans mon coffre fort en banque
c'est comme un diamant ou de l'artois
c'est compliqué de le cacher sous son
matelas
[Musique]
ici tu as un booster cette de base
édition 1 fois la petite différence se
fait au niveau de la bastille donc je
serais vraiment les tout premiers qui
sont sortis en france aujourd'hui c'est
très très très rare et un booster comme
ça qui est lourd une vend aujourd'hui
entre 2 et 3000 euros
[Musique]
écarté pleuvoir actuellement sur le
marché on a le pikachu ministre a tort
qui est la fameuse carte quasi
introuvable et qui vaut plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros et vous
avez également la carte la fameuse carte
monde entendu parler celle de logan paul
le youtuber américain donc le dracaufeu
édition 1
est ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est
shadow laisse j'adresse c'est quoi ça
veut dire que vous n'avez pas l'ombre
en fait c'est un défaut d'impression sur
les premières cartes aux états unis vous
n'avez pas les londres autour des
retours du cadre qui en a tellement peu
que ça vaut des prix astronomiques
il y en a qui se sont rendus 3 500 mille
euros
[Musique]
mais si demain tu veux vendre une carte
pokémon tu as deux choix soit tu l'as
fait certifier soit tu la vends tel quel
fossard qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent
d'acheteurs qui sont réfractaires au
fait d'acheter sans notes parce que
d'une part on peut pas vérifier
l'authenticité / photo et deuxièmement
on peut pas vérifier l'état la deuxième
manière c'est de faire certifier ces
quartiers la meilleure manière pour moi
de pouvoir estimer la valeur d'une carte
tout simplement parce que vous allez
avoir une note
cette note a indiqué l'état de la carte
deuxièmement elle est protégé en cas
d'envoi etc et surtout sa affirme que la
carte est authentique parce
qu'aujourd'hui les notations sont faites
par des professionnels etc
donc voilà c'est un gage de garantie en
fait donc là je te montre le tome 3 de
mes cartes ayant le plus de valeur
j'étais ramener plutôt que du récent
mais du coup le fameux dracaufeu shiny
que tout le monde s'arrache aujourd'hui
j'en ai vu partir en pc à 9 aux
alentours des 4 500 euros ensuite tu as
celui là donc pareil c'est un droit
qu'au fur mbow très très compliqué à
obtenir pareil on est dans les mêmes à
un tour des prix à peu près sauf que
celui là est un 9 et demi et donc du
coup ça peut côté un peu plus et enfin
ceux dracaufeu rainbow gx2 soyez une
ombre ardente qui lui vaut très très
cher si tu obtiens une belle note quoi
là moi j'ai eu 8 mai en dise j'ai vu des
prix qui défient l'entendement
la différence de prix entre une carte
qui est en bon état une carte qui est
extrêmement 9
ça peut faire x 10 clairement ça peut
faire x 10 pour reconnaître une carte
fausses et a par exemple l'âge est un
booster ici donc je vais te montrer
rapide
j'ai pas de booster de fausses mais
effectivement il ya énormément de
possibles qui circulent sur le marché
là tu vois je prendre ces cartes là par
exemple je vais prendre ma carte énergie
pour moi c'est la technique la plus
fiable
en fait ce qu'il faut c'est que tu
déchire la carte en fait
donc je prends une carte énergie parce
qu'avec moins de valeur et etc et
l'association voit bien sûr ta caméra
mais il ya une espèce des petites en
prob le juste en dessous tu as une autre
bleue et sur les fausses cartes toutes
les fausses cartes que moi j'ai eu entre
les mains cette encre bleue n'existe pas
attention vous fait passer avec un
dracaufeu pour me dire regarde il est
vrai parce que sinon il va perdre sa
valeur les gars après tu as une deuxième
technique aussi c'est celle d'un peu de
la plier généralement les cartes
officielles reprennent leur forme
initiale les fausses adresses pliant y
tour à première estime la valeur de ma
collection pokémon je dirais que ça
tourne autour des entre quinze et vingt
mille euros si on prend toutes les
pièces que j'ai peut-être un peu plus
peut-être un peu moins ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le marché
pokémon fluctuent énormément c'est un
petit peu comme les crypto monnaie ça
monte ça descend ça monte ça descend en
soit il ya énormément de collectionneurs
en france qui ont des collections qui
valent le double triple 100 fois la
mienne et ça c'est des gens c'est des
gens qui plus tard je pense deviendront
les nouveaux riches comme comme sont
devenus des riches
qui avaient des billets du big town
[Musique]